a glimpse inside the self-imposed
confinement and monotony that was Julian
Assange's life for seven years a
security camera shows the rooms inside
the Ecuadorian Embassy where the
WikiLeaks founder languished under
diplomatic protection and therefore
immunity from arrest but mr. Assange is
lawyer has denied claims he upset his
hosts by amongst other things
spreading feces on the walls it's a
difficult situation I've been visiting
him in the embassy for throughout this
seven-year period it's he hasn't had
outside access to the outside he's been
inside a room effectively as you said
for more than seven years people have
children who are six and seven years old
for that for your child's entire life
this man has been inside a room in quite
difficult circumstances now the politics
of the case with respect to Ecuador
change with a change of government with
Linamar Daniel coming to power and ever
since then inside the embassy it's
become more and more difficult to the
point where even Human Rights Watch said
it was akin to solitary confinement
Ecuador allowed British police to haul
away Julian Assange on Thursday he
maintains he stayed not to avoid rape
allegations in Sweden but because he
feared extradition to America for
exposing US government secrets
the Swedish prosecutors came inside the
Ecuadorian embassy to ask him questions
about the case he gave his testimony and
after that they chose to close the
investigation three days after his
arrest and the Ecuador embassy is now
devoid of Assange supporters but his
critics say no charges in Sweden doesn't
amount to exoneration my understanding
is that the only reason the Swedish
authorities have not prosecuted the case
is simply because they couldn't get him
into a Swedish Court it isn't because
they were satisfied that there was no
everything evidence against him there's
no case to answer on the contrary in
fact in Sweden in 2017 the director of
public prosecution in announcing the
rape investigation was being
discontinued suggested mr. Assange is
stay at the Embassy was hindering their
investigation
she said the motive is that there is no
reason to believe that the decision to
surrender him to Sweden can be
executed in the foreseeable future now
mr. Assange is short-term fate is in the
hands of Britain's Home Secretary
if Sweden does press charges as to
whether he would be sent there or to
America he would base his decision on
the seriousness of the allegations which
request was made first whether or not
the person is a fugitive or not and
whether they're simply wanted for trial
or whether they're convicted of an
offense after so long in one room
ultimately Julian Assange probably will
end up abroad for judgment to be passed
on just how his actions will go down in
history Lisa Holland Sky News